foreign
to addressing racial disparities in
health care thanks to all of our
participants who are joining us today
from all around the world this webinar
is brought to you by Harvard online and
the disparities Solutions Center at
Massachusetts General Hospital
before we get started I'll run through
some basic information on our webinar
foreign
so all participants will stay muted and
the chat function will be turned off for
the duration of the event
we do want to hear from you though so
questions can be submitted using the Q a
button that you'll see at the top of
your Zoom screen
or you can submit questions through the
comments section if you're joining us
via live stream
for the last 15 minutes of the webinar
the participants will answer your
question so we encourage you to share
you can also upvote questions that
resonate with you
this event is being presented in
conjunction with the launch of our
latest course reducing racial
disparities in health care which begins
on Wednesday March 8
2023. applications are due February 27th
when the webinar is over we'll be
sending a discount code to all
participants in the chat as well as an
email that will go out following the
webinar
we are excited to introduce you to our
moderator and panelists for today's
event
our moderator is a Sweda tan mcgrory one
of the faculty who teaches our upcoming
course reducing racial disparities in
health care
she is also the director of the
disparity Solutions Center and director
of equity and Care implementation at
Massachusetts General Hospital
thank you for joining us
and I'll let you introduce the rest of
our panelists
thank you Jim I want to welcome
everybody and thank them for joining us
today
and I have uh three colleagues and also
friends with me today I have Dr Lenny
Lopez Andrea madou and as Dr Esteban
Barreto and so I'm going to kick off
this webinar we're going to have a
lively discussion and as was previously
mentioned if you have questions please
submit them through the Q a function uh
and we will use the last 15 minutes to
to go through this but first I want to
ask each of the panelists to go ahead
and introduce themselves and then really
kind of let us know like what is sort of
the driving force in in it for you in
doing this work around addressing racial
and ethnic disparities and working on
equity and uh Lenny I'll start with you
and then Andrea I'll have you go second
well thank you sweet that's wonderful to
be here and uh on this panel on this
very important topic my name is Lenny
Lopez and I am a professor of medicine
and the chief of Hospital medicine at
the University of California San
Francisco and the VA Medical Center here
and I'm also a healthcare disparities uh
researcher and implementation science
researcher I think for me uh disparities
work and elimination of disparities and
really bringing Equity into Healthcare
comes from my family experiences and
also my patient care every day I see
individuals that are challenged by
access barriers challenges around
language barriers uh lack of access to
high quality care and most importantly
from the moment that they enter the
healthcare system from registration all
the way to their outcomes Equity has to
be the number one true north so that's
really my my my passion and energy comes
from that
thank you Lenny Andrea hi everyone my
name is Andrew madhu so happy to be here
and excited to have a conversation on
this topic I am currently a consultant
at the bridge band group and I work
largely with non-profits and
philanthropists to accelerate their
impact and solve really tough challenges
centered around Equity but I started my
career in healthcare working to address
disparities for youth regarding HIV AIDS
and then working at the DSC with the
panelists on this call
I'm really interested in this work
because I've seen for myself the
differential treatment that people
receive based on language proficient
proficiency my family emigrated from
Nigeria in the 80s and I remember going
to the hospital as a child and seeing
how doctors treated my grandmother who
could not speak English very different
from me and my siblings and also my mom
who speaks English fluently but has a
strong accent would have to use her
knowledge as a nurse to really navigate
the Health Care system and for her to
get respect and be treated with the
respect that she deserved so those
experiences have always fueled me to
work on reducing Health disparities in
health care and I've seen how this poor
treatment can translate to poor outcomes
for patients
and then personally for myself I know
there's a very high maternal mortality
rate for black women regardless of class
and I've always been terrified of the
prospect of giving birth because I know
what the outcomes are for people who
look like me and so I'm always terrified
for my family members even though
they're in the medical profession
so in a way it affects me it affects the
people in my family and that realization
has wanted me has made me want to
advocate for people who may not have the
privilege and knowledge to navigate
through that Health Care system
thank you Andrea Esteban
thank you Sweda
um great to be here thank you so much
for the invitation uh similarly to Lenny
and Andrea
um a lot of my passion for this work
comes from lived experience as an
immigrant to the US myself I I also had
to navigate different systems with my
family
um especially the the medical system and
having family members
go through different language barriers
really allowed me to
um to to focus on this type of work I
would also say from early in college I
started working as a research assistant
and and worked in a variety of different
research and quality improvement
projects and and that gave me a great
exposure into inclusive data collection
techniques
um you know also different sampling
techniques that we could use that that
allows us to hear from those patients
who may otherwise be excluded from
routine in assessments so we'll say It's
a combination of both lived experience
and also early professional experience
with it it really allowed me to explore
barriers uh in in a more tailored way
and hear from those voices who may as I
said May otherwise be excluded from from
different assessments once again great
to be here and on this important
conversation
thank you I I think the overwhelming
theme I'm hearing is this is personal to
us right a very personal I mean not only
do we are we motivated because you know
as many people say it's the right thing
to do but also we it resonates with many
of us it's it's the people that we love
that we see as patients
um it's it's the experiences we had
um in you know in our past childhood so
I think there's a lot here when we do
this work and I think it's also a way
that we have to sort of protect
ourselves and just put that out there
this is tough work
um and you know having a community of
like-minded colleagues and friends like
you guys goes a long way into you know
creating that sort of safe space
um a lot has changed in this field since
the pandemic and I kind of want to talk
about that because we were doing this
work before the pandemic
um really launched the center with the
ium report unequal treatment and so we
have seen sort of this Arc of how this
has changed and I would say the last
three years in particular has been sort
of amazing but also challenging so I
would love to hear from you
um you know from your perspective how
has the field changed and how we do this
work and I'll start with Andrea and then
Estevan have you go second
sure so I'll caveat that I was working
in philanthropy during this time but I
was working with a lot of organizations
that are addressing the social
determinants of health and are kind of
working in tandem with hospitals I
remember before the pandemic it was
always an uphill battle to try and
convince people why this work was
important we had the data but the data
hadn't come into sharp Focus yet once
the pandemic hit and it was very clear
that one leaders of color were on the
front lines and we're also having a
higher rate of covid and then the
service providers as well were from the
same background all of a sudden everyone
was investing in these organizations led
by people of color who've been doing
this work since the beginning we're
taking on an extra burden and so it
really did bring into sharp Focus the
idea that this pandemic is something
everyone's dealing with but it's
actually affecting these specific
populations so that was to me exciting
to see because finally the work that we
had been doing was was was very evident
but then kind of a few years later and
coming back to that work because the
pandemic has been declared it over even
though people are still dealing with
this I I fear that there's kind of a
retracting now where like that knowledge
is kind of going backwards and less of a
focus is on it so
I think in my opinion I think we've
moved forward but then there's kind of a
pendulum swing back where I think more
of that work needs to continue to be
done so that people are still educated
and why this is important
yeah I think the burnout rate is high on
a topic like this uh can be Esteban what
do you think
yeah and I I agree with um with the
points that Andrea brought and also U.S
Rita said that Allah has changed since
the pandemic I remember right before the
pandemic I was still working on my
doctoral dissertation which focused on
um the effects of diversity work culture
on different organizational outcomes and
I remember when I was trying to argue
for the need of having a diverse work
culture
um it wasn't as clear I I felt you know
there were a lot of pieces that I was I
was you know trying to really argue for
but then during the pandemic you know as
you know there was an increased sense of
urgency you know I I I feel like if I
would have written that dissertation
during the pandemic or after the
pandemic I wouldn't had to explain
myself so much in terms of the
importance of having a diverse Workforce
particularly in healthcare settings
um were were we serve diverse patient
populations
um so yeah so I think it it increases a
sense of
urgency a lot of people wanted to know
about it
you know leaders focusing not only
um you know their their efforts their
resources but undering their values uh
the professional and and but yet there's
a lot of work that has to be done
um I also agree with Andrea that there
may be you know
um some backtracking uh at the moment
not not sure what that really is about
but but but especially during the first
uh waves of the pandemic we did see a
lot of energy in in trying to tackle
these barriers
you know it raised an interesting point
and Lenny you and I have talked about
this this idea that I think everybody
can now get on board the importance of
diversifying our Workforce our team our
providers uh and that seems a
comfortable space to a certain extent
for people to talk about us particularly
in healthcare but this idea of like and
it has to be paired with Equitable care
or making sure that there's no racial
and ethnic disparities has sort of
gotten
um less traction
um Lenny can you talk a little bit about
that sort of from your perspective of
overseeing you know Hospital medicine in
a in a clinical setting
um and being the chief like the
challenges of that
this
yeah I'm reflecting on what you're
saying we're also with Andrea bosteban
was sharing you know you know over 20
years ago uh you know some type of
medicine not only the national academies
of Medicine Science and Engineering put
out a report on equal treatment and 20
years ago the field was just beginning
the notion of collecting data around
race of Michigan language and at that
point we had to justify that and we had
to create you know dreams of research
and papers and all of these things
policy white papers in order to say this
was an important issue and I think the
acceleration that's happened in the last
few years has shifted not only the
public discourse but also the shift to
structural changes that are needed in
within institutions and between
institutions at both the government
level all the way down through the
Health Care system so the focus has
become less on individuals and more on
how the structures that we have created
as as the Healthcare System perpetuate
inequities how can we change those
things and so there is a level of
comfort that wasn't there you know even
five years ago around well how do we
actually bring about the equity that we
all feel sort of when it has been put in
Center uh so it's the latest uh yeah
just social justice uh movements of
George Floyd the novels who have
suffered so much so I think the
discussion really really has shifted in
in that direction so bringing that
Equity back into the Forefront into the
center of the discussion that that's
really where we're going
um and so data collection is very
important for monitoring and assuring
quality but at the same time we need
structural changes that will allow for
True change over time to occur so I
think that's really different and very
exciting about the work that we have in
front of us moving forward
yeah and I you know I it's interesting
because I think there's a lot more
buy-in but at the same time people are
very overwhelmed with what it would take
this idea of structural racism I feel is
fairly new to many folks
um and and I wonder Lenny or even Andrea
nazimon if you feel that sometimes this
idea that it's structural racism plays a
role and it plays a very big role and I
don't know that we as a country have
really acknowledged historically how
things have been designed
um and but do you think that gives
certain people sort of like the feeling
of a past like oh it's not me it's you
know these things that I can't change
and control
well I I would add
um of that very briefly I'll let Andrea
uh as respond as well is that there is
an element of that and there's also that
sense of being overwhelmed and realizing
how deep and large the problem is and
that is not a problem that just started
yesterday but it's been several hundred
years that have allowed us to get to
where we are so when people throw their
hands up in the air it could be the pass
that's probably the element we all want
to feel that we're not you know causing
injury to others but it's also the sense
of where do I begin and how does this
start and what happened here so I think
it's all of that mixed together but I
don't I want to give angry an
opportunity to share her thoughts as
well
I agree Lenny that there's a sense of
overwhelm I think people really resonate
with interpersonal racism like my
additional actions what can I do and
what have I done that's caused harm but
when you kind of zoom out the systemic
lens and noticing that it's everywhere
it's like you're a fish in water and
it's all over you I think it is
overwhelming for people but on the other
side I found that I've seen that like
aha moment that happens with people when
they start to realize oh this is like
historic disinvestment and this has
happened over years and it's all layered
and I think for some people who want to
do that work that that education is so
important I think we they can't people
can't use overwhelm as a reason not to
do the work I've seen the overwhelm
happen but I've also seen that transform
into what can I do and how can we break
down some of the barriers
institutionally and I think the course
especially like Works through that and
talks through the history of racism in
the U.S and it kind of lays it in a way
that you really can't deny what's going
on and just talks more about tangible
ways to to address that yeah I feel like
that was a key piece for us to include
in our course was that we have to
acknowledge how we got here right and it
is not something that is easy to talk
about but I think uh Dr Powell does a
wonderful job of sort of walking us
through and it can be very eye-opening a
lot of it is stuff that we did not learn
in school
and I think a lot of people were
surprised by some of the things he
shared uh and you know so I think that's
like a key element that we have sort of
built into the course that we need to
start opening up Esteban
yeah I certainly agree with Lenny and
Andrea in terms of the overwhelming
aspect and and also with Andrea's point
about how it shouldn't be an excuse uh
education is is where you know we should
really focus fortunately we live in you
know uh some of us live in Massachusetts
where we're still allowed to teach
things a critical race Theory
um you know in in terms of racism you
know I know there's a lot of different
definitions uh and and people may have
different nuances I think of racism as a
system of Oppression
um and then you know from that there's a
lot of different types of racism and
racial discrimination and all that and I
think that that that that is a good
point a good starting point you know the
education of these Concepts
um and how this this phenomena affects
different populations
um but again you know I also agree with
the earlier point from Lenny about the
structural challenges and and we can do
a whole lot in terms of of data
collection and trying to learn from
different perspectives but then if these
structures and and unfortunately the
politics get in the way
um it's it just makes our job much much
harder
you know it's a good point you make
about sort of you know
um people sometimes ask me like well how
do you know that Equity has been
achieved and I would say you know Equity
is not the end goal because it is really
a journey and it consistently has to be
monitored it has to be deliberate you
know we are always learning something
new in this field I feel it's constantly
changing terminology changes funding
changes right people's willingness to
talk about it we've definitely seen a
huge change
I mean there are I think a couple years
ago just mentioning the word racism in a
boardroom like everybody's shoulders
would be like this you know and so now
we're saying it yeah I I remember we we
I mean you try to do whatever you can to
bring the message along so you're like
okay let me just soften it
you know and I'm I'm happy to see that
we can say the word racism without
stuttering uh in in boardrooms I mean I
feel like that's progress uh and and so
this is really a journey I'm curious to
hear from you three what do you think we
really need in a field like what is the
gap like there's a lot here you know
interpersonal racism structural racism
if we think about like healthcare
organizations and Healthcare in general
like what is needed from your
perspective
what one thing I I wanted to add up to
your report to answer your question add
to the conversation is is that what is
needed is not only I love this Frame of
Journey also just continued growth as
part of that Journey you know I'm happy
to share that even after 20 years
working in the field of equity and
Healthcare disparities I I'm constantly
learning and I'm constantly being pushed
and I'm constantly needing to reflect on
my own implicit biases and my my own
starting point and my own sort of
um ability to communicate these things
in the right settings with the different
different groups of people and I think
those are things that are forced like
this can really give you that space no
matter what your love will experience or
background or education around these
topics it is it is really as you're
saying it's either a personal Journey so
I think one of the things that when the
sports uh it comes live and I'll
encourage other folks to take it is
really to realize that you don't know
everything and so much space where you
can actually continue to grow as an
individual and make those changes in
your own place in the universe where you
are at work and in your communities
yeah and I I will say like you know we
have long discussions about content when
we started designing this course and and
there's probably stuff that we weren't
able to include because honestly to
include everything right
um your course would be a full year and
then you would still probably leave
things out so I think we really tried to
focus on what we know best from all the
organizations that we've worked with
what we're sort of the core competencies
that we would want you to know what
would be some of the building blocks
that you as a person you know having to
sort of think about transforming your
organization to think about racial
ethnic disparities to think about you
know Equity like what are some of the
key components and really bringing in
the folks that we've worked with so I I
totally agree that that
um
um with your point Lenny Andrew and
Esteban
yeah I agree too Lenny that humility is
so important and I think humility was
something I felt throughout this course
the idea that Equity is not something
that we're going to solve in our
lifetimes but there are pieces of it
that we can move along a journey
um while we're working on it and so I
think that was very very helpful to see
um I think also just in general
structurally I think what's needed is a
pipeline of doctors who also looks like
the communities that are serving and
have that lived experience to understand
the cultural context of you know what
patients are saying that's one and then
I also think this understanding of the
medical mistrust that has happened over
decades or centuries and understanding
you know why some people might not want
to come to the doctor or why people
might not be adhering to treatments
there are reasons behind that and I
think really coming to it with both
humility and empathy to patients I think
is so important and that kind of goes
into the frame of understanding the
history behind everything
yes and I definitely agree with what it
was said definitely a journey
um we we have to exercise humility I you
know Andrea to come and had me thinking
about how we moved from cultural
competence to culture of humility right
so maybe we have to think about Equity
humility
um and you know it is it is not easy to
address Healthcare disparities where
when there are also disparities in
education disparities in the legal
system and everything you know kind of
has a an effect on each other right so
in order to to increase representation
among health professionals you also have
to address disparities and equal
opportunity to education you know what
um children and and young adults are
being exposed to it in terms of future
career so I think as a society there's a
lot that we still need to work on
um you know
um we're we're talking more um in
particular about Healthcare disparities
but I just wanted to to make that point
that that it's you know this there is a
really everywhere in every single system
so so we we also have to think about
tackling it
um in in other Fabrics of
um of our society
um one thing about these scores is that
considering how complex this issue is
um the speakers do explain the topics in
a very
um comprehensive manner uh in in in
providing examples providing different
case scenarios that um I was really
happy with it and I found it very easy
to follow along uh and and I also have
to admit that I did learn a lot of
things
um despite having a few years working on
this field
yeah Andrea and Estevan uh were the
um early adopters of the course they
they actually went through the course
and
um you know I just want to thank you
first of all for taking the time to do
that but it's very meaningful to me that
somebody like you I gave it a seal of
approval and that you still learn
something new I think that's an
important uh theme that you know Lenny
and all of you have brought up is that
um you know when people talk about
subject matter experts I say oh that's
for the caveat because to be honest I'm
constantly learning new things
um I'm constantly you know you in this
work you have to self-reflect uh that's
really the only area where you can make
some concrete changes but you have to
reflect on your own Journey your own
reaction to some of what you work on
every day
um and then also like it just changes it
changes constantly it depends hands
who's you know in leadership positions
whether it's in this country or in your
institution it depends on like where the
fun the money's going
um so there's there's a lot of sort of
factors and um so I agree like I feel
like if you're you're not learning
anything new then maybe
I don't know that you're ready because I
feel like we're constantly like learning
um we are sort of early adopters
um
it's probably because
we've been doing this work so long and I
just I'm just kind of curious like from
your perspective
um in just sort of giving some some like
on hindsight I wish I had known this
when doing this work like what are some
things that you would share with the
audience
from whatever role you feel is most
comfortable whether it's like a
physician leadership role where it's
it's about as sort of you know
um evaluation component or Andrea as
like a consultant with like a really
heavy vested interest in this in this
topic
or from a personal perspective
so I could talk about the the evaluation
work one thing that I wish I knew before
is that you know we we love uh timelines
and deadlines and all of that in an
Ideal World
um you know we are able to meet all the
deadlines for all of our projects but
then the projects that have more of an
equity lens of a healthy disparities
lens
um I feel like you need to be a little
bit more flexible and and sometimes
pivot right so when you may plan the
perfect goal the perfect objective
um you may come up with a perfect
approach to data collection and then you
you may learn that there's things that
you may need to change right and so I so
I wish that that was one component that
that I learned uh early on uh but now
that is something that I do stress when
when I do meet with different
investigators who are interested in
having an equity lens uh to their
research portfolio and and we talk about
that flexibility or or that ability to
Pivot when needed
I think one thing I wish I had known is
one like how to identify people who
their minds are just never going to be
changed no matter what you do
um but I wish I had learned those
strategies to kind of transform the
hearts and Minds around those people
because really that's how it works um to
get those allies on your side I think
there's one piece of the course that
talks about the Cotter model and I think
I've always thought of creating a sense
of urgency was the most important piece
but there's all these pieces of creating
the Coalition but then also trying to
use that coalition to get other people
involved and invested and that's really
what pushes these initiatives to be
successful more so than just saying this
is why this is important so I wish I had
known that before
um I think now it's really important in
the work that I do now and I especially
in this Healthcare work where you are
going to have to change hearts and minds
and how do you do that when you know you
might not be the right messenger for the
message but you could find that person
to help you along the way yeah it was
very helpful you know the Conor model
isn't designed for Equity but when I
read his his book I was like oh my God
like this is it this is the template of
like why it's so hard to change an
organization right like really all the
way through
um and and it's it it's when you to talk
about organizational transformation he's
identified what makes it successful
um so I I think that's a very helpful
grounding in sort of this work when you
kind of feel like oh I don't know like
why is it that I've been doing this work
for five years but it feels like I've
got no traction
um then then I think that model was like
from a business perspective very helpful
Lenny
yeah you know when you're reflecting on
what everyone is sharing you know one of
the things that that I've learned over
time the working with an organization
working within my own organization
um to address uh systemic barriers is
that all the sources of disparities and
the solutions for eliminating those
disparities are all hyper local and that
you can learn the goal is to learn tools
and strategies for example the common
model we're talking about
um to really then take it home and take
it to your institution to your
organization to your community
um and your place in the universe and
that's where the change happens and so
although we have oftentimes grandiose
ideas about how the world is going to
change and all these things oftentimes
it's much smaller victories that add up
over time and so those are the things
where we're as needed to use your
metaphor of the journey those are the
things that give you strength and forage
and the energy to keep doing the work
and so reframing and organizing your
thinking in that way essentially what's
available in this course is an
incredibly helpful uh process to grow
through
um so I my last question to all three of
you is you know this is hard work
um I do feel like once you see things
you can't unsee them and then you see
them everywhere like if you go on
vacation
in the grocery store
um and and so my question to you is how
do you do self-care in this work like I
love that all four of us have the lived
experience it allows me not to have to
do the Preamble of like why this is
important right I can just skip that and
go straight to like how can we do things
but I really would love to hear from you
how what is the self-care strategy you
use and all mine for example is I don't
read outside of this job any heavy books
on racism uh social justice I don't
watch movies about it I just I've had
enough like I watch really bad trash TV
and read
um detective novels but it's I just know
that's I need to refill my tank so I
would love to hear
um from the three of you your strategy
for doing that because I think that's an
important piece of all of this work
um is the self-care so um I'll start
with Esteban and then Andrea and then
I'll close it out with Lenny
yeah for me uh some strategies for
self-care is I mean family and friends
uh having open discussions about
different issues
um I do have to admit that I I try my
best to stay current to to the news and
everything that is going on
um you know and I learned how to not you
know take things personally over the
years
um also another big part for me is
working with students I'm an instructor
at the School of Social Work at Simmons
and United teacher class there each
semester and and working with different
students really allowed me to also stay
current in different topics for example
social issues the different nuances
different different ways that issues are
being looked at
um and and so so those are some of the
things that do help me to stay current
but but also trying to practice some
self-care yeah there's nothing like
working with young students
to get out
you know sort of the old archaic way of
thinking and it's sort of refreshing
Andrea yeah I feel like I I plug it a
lot because of my work I really have to
stay current as well I have a group chat
with my family where I'm just like
anytime something crazy happens I'm just
like can you believe this and we just
kind of dish on it and it makes me feel
like you know I'm Not Alone
um I also like schedule 30 minutes
before and I have a big meeting with
someone that I know is going to be like
a struggle to go on a walk or I like
listen to some of my favorite music just
to get me kind of hyped up to deal with
that
um but yeah just creating space for Joy
I think it's so important to find Joy
wherever you can in this world because I
know it is it's tough but those moments
do exist and I really enjoy working with
people who are just as passionate about
it yeah that's a good point about the
chat I think we all have folks that we
text you where it's like oh my God this
person just said this can you believe it
and then they'll ping back and like I
can and I'm really sorry and that's
really all sometimes you need Lenny
yeah you know similarly to to all of uh
through all of the panelists uh I'm just
thrilled that we're even having the
conversation about self-care in this
space because I think even even 10 years
ago we weren't talking about self-care
and for those of us doing Equity work
and Justice work and realizing that you
have to give yourself that space and
that condition and realize that the work
is larger than yourself and so your
answer the time that you put into it the
education the forces the things you do
the work you do every day those are all
part of a larger change a larger uh
process that you're a part of and you're
adding to but it is not all you and I
think that is really liberating but I'm
so thrilled that we talk about self-care
these days because it's so essential to
not be uh the hero that dies because of
the weight of inequity and Injustice in
the world so very very very important
yes I mean if we think of about reducing
the stress so that we have better health
outcomes yes self-care is a big
component because because the the data
shows
we're not winning in this spot at all
okay
um I think we're going to turn to some
audience questions thank you for for
that I I you know I think that's an
important piece that we didn't sort of
talk about in the course but I wanted to
highlight in the webinar so I think
there's been a lot of questions and
um
I'm okay first question can you outline
some of the tangible ways to address
racial inequities in health care well
tactical practical steps can be taken
now
um aside from taking the course
which outline knows
um maybe let's see anybody want to sort
of take that question on
well it's a very large question and it
comes back to my comments about the
sources of disparities of the solutions
of disparities being hyper local so for
example for me as a clinical leader at a
very large university the the what we
what we've been doing for many years is
starting from the process the poor
people engage our health care System the
whole process of registration the
process having access to a healthcare
and actually structuring it to prevent
the blind spots to prevent the processes
that will lead to inequity and then
building at every level from that moment
of registration to the clinical care to
the training of the providers to the
measurement of outcomes to the reporting
public reporting of those outcomes on
and on at each step of the way may sound
not sexy but that's actually how change
happens and how equities establish in an
institution institutional setting so
that would be the beginning of a
conversation about the the answer to
that question that this is actually deep
work that requires every level of the
institution to be involved in
I could add to that to treat patients as
the subject matter Experts of their
lives because there's so much
information that can be gleaned just by
having that rapport with a patient and I
think in designing Solutions like Lenny
saying they're hyper local I think that
also means just having people within the
community that are trusted to understand
like where the core issues are
understand the root causes before we
kind of go into like the treatment
aspect of it so I think bringing the
community in and building that trust as
well
estiman did you have any comments yeah I
agree with with Lenny uh and Andrea the
only thing I will add is um you know if
you know we all know that if you're
trying to to find disparities and you
look for them you will find them right
and um you know after you take the
course or while you're taking the course
and you're thinking about a particular
project that you would like to embark on
I'll suggest that you get
um as specific as you can in your
project you know one of the things that
I see from my students for example is
that their their their goals are very
broad right and we're all trying to
solve everything in the world uh and and
and unfortunately we may not have the
bandwidth so I will say uh at the
individual project level
um you know the more specific you get
the more
um tailor
um the the better
um you the more successful you will be
to measure and and keep track of um of
the progress yeah try not to boil the
ocean I think the other piece are going
back bouncing back to what Lenny said is
you know I do think data collection that
is a tangible step that you can take is
to to assess the quality of your
demographic data
um because out of that comes a lot and
then I would say taking a journey and
looking around in your community and
seeing what are some of the historical
Milestones things events that happened
that created the mistrust in the
communities that you serve between the
communities and your organization we
don't like to do that but we have to I
think that's core to understanding
whether you know our interventions or
our strategies are going to work they
won't work if we don't acknowledge
um some of the historical events that
have created a lot of the mistrust we
have to do that hard work I just want to
quickly add to what you you're saying
this you know what Andrea was saying is
that in this course and in this more if
you have to realize that you're creating
Partnerships and allyships you're not
going into a community to save a
community and those those approaches uh
act as if the communities have no
resilience no no empowerment no
resources Etc it's often not the case
um so it's really that that connection
where the community and the systems and
institutions work together that lead to
long-lasting change
um and because institutions are within
communities whether they want to think
about that or not
yeah
um this is a good question I get this a
lot when I um we do presentations for
like an international audience which is
do you feel like racial disparities and
discrimination is a bigger problem in
the United States and in healthcare in
particular or do you see similar issues
internationally
so I could start by saying that
something to keep in mind is that the
way that we conceptualize these Concepts
differ
um you know in each country even the
concept of race is very different the
way that we think about it here in the
U.S versus it started in Latin America
in Europe Etc so
um that's something that I should say
you know to keep in mind that a lot of
these constructs a lot of these concepts
are you know are particular to a
particular culture country and also
Moment In Time
yeah I would also say like again would
Echo that that racism is seen
differently uh racism's twin sister is
colonialism and there's colonialism all
over the world that has affected
populations I think any uh Community
where you see there's a gradation and
color the people who are the darkest
skin are generally the ones that are
facing the most discrimination and you
will find disparities there as well so I
think just because the conception is
different it doesn't mean that those
sick disparities don't exist
um it's just that I think in like the us
we talk about it more and it's like we
have this history of slavery as well
um for hundreds of years so I think it's
just a difference of of familiarity with
the concept yeah and I would say you
know my home country is the Netherlands
and it's it's known as a very tolerant
country but even if we sort of look
deeper under the hood you know there's
immigrant populations who are you know
not getting
um you know the same treatment as as
somebody who is Dutch and born there
there's also religious oppression
um that's probably mirrors the same
thing so there there's there's and then
there's you know tribal as well we have
you know tribal differences so I
I would say it's really about what kind
of social justice and oppression is in
you know do you need to look at rather
than thinking that you know racial and
ethnic disparities is just a U.S problem
that's sort of denying that your country
may also have issues
um
yeah and I would add to what everyone is
saying and I think it's also a false
dichotomy because in reality you whether
it raises the discussion point or social
economics is the social you know the
point or uh colonialism history is the
point all of them become deeply
interrelated over time so when you try
to separate one out the other is still
embedded in it you know and so I I tend
to tell people that whether the terms
are that are more Primary in a context
um are meaningful to people realizing
that they're actually very similar and
they're very correlated so trying to
separate those out is often leads you to
confusing uh conclusions
um that I'm usually not true
okay I have one more question and then
um we'll close it out
um and and Lenny maybe I'll I'll sort of
um
point this to you so how can we
integrate training on reducing
disparities in formal medical training
how can medical students carry this
workout medical students are the Next
Generation right and so we have to be
really mindful of of being able to to to
focus on them because that is a wave of
change as we see it so any thoughts on
that question
great question and think about this a
lot uh given that I have trained he's
always working with me and that is is
that the only way to do it is that it
has to be actually embedded in the four
years of a medical school breaking from
the very beginning
um and the not only the content but the
the making space formal space for
reflection we're mentoring or
observation of what other senior doctors
may be doing handling these kinds of
issues in the clinical context so it
actually has to be part of the culture
um and that is done through the
investment of money and time protecting
Educators times to actually be able to
teach this material as opposed to
volunteerism you know really embedding
it in you know this is an essential
topic that every year we're going to
discuss throughout the coursework but
again that takes time money and
investment from the leadership of the
institution so very very important that
we're going to really change uh the
needle but it can't be a niche topic
that's done in a you know small 10-hour
uh seminar uh once or twice in four
years that's not that is not going to
work
multi-pronged effort definitely
um I want to thank the three of you for
you know
joining me in this conversation I knew
that we would have a good conversation
um I stacked the deck by asking highly
intelligent friends and colleagues to
join me on the panel who I really like
that that just that just is very helpful
and makes it I knew all of you would
show up and that you would bring your
your authentic self and your lived
experience and your thoughtfulness uh to
this webinar so thank you again uh and
I'm now going to turn it over to Jim uh
to close us out
great thank you sweeta and thank you
Lenny Esteban and Andrea and thanks to
all of you who've joined us today we
hope you'll continue the conversation in
our new online course reducing racial
disparities in health care which is
launching on
um March 8th enrollment is now open
applications are due by February 27th
and everyone who's registered for this
webinar today will receive a discount
code
off the course uh in the chat as well as
an email that you'll be receiving soon
so thank you again for participating
and we appreciate your time today